angels will be going with andrew haney
29 year old left-hander his record is
just one in three this season he will
face cesar hernandez for the indians
in
two of his seven starts this season the
first batter he's faced in two of those
seven starts
they've hammered against them
and the next pitch and that one will not
be a home run that's a swing and a miss
and that is out number one jose ramirez
the batter
the one-two swung on and lifted high in
the air deep left field home run jose
ramirez
and the indians grab the early lead at
two nothing
number 12 on the season for ramirez
well they have a great chance here
runners at second and third harold
ramirez the batter who's been swinging
the bat well
right side grumble gets by the second
baseman gosling and the indians will get
another run
and here comes rosario throw to the
plate not in time oh what a daring dash
to home plate by eddie rosario and it's
a four run first for cleveland
took advantage of an angels defense with
their head down and joe madden could
bite through his mask right now
here's you chang here's the pitch to
chang he swings and skies it to right
near the line
rojas is over and he makes the catch
tagging heading for home is ramirez the
throw is up the line ramirez scores
and it's now a five-nothing tribe lead
in the top half of the first
hedges is hitting just
137
here's the 3-2 pitch and it's popped up
this should end the inning out near
second base iglesias the shortstop he's
almost on the bag he's so close to it
he'll make the catch and that is how the
inning ends
but a big inning for the indians they
put five on the board and that will be
zac zlizek who's three and three this
year and eight starts in era at 3.56
here's shohei ohtani digging in
next delivery and this is a blast in the
center field and my goodness it is way
out of here
it clears the
big hedges out there in dead center
tape measure home run for ohtani puts
the angels on the board here it's now
5-1 and
early tonight it's showtime
ohtani now home runs in three straight
games and four out of the last five
games
dead center field ohtani number 14.
anthony rendon
hitting 274 three homers a dozen driven
in
one out basis empty
please sack into the wind his pitch
called strike three on the inside corner
fastball catches rendon looking
two down in the inning so they have
runners at first and second still two
outs here's eddie rosario batting lefty
hitter
counts two and one now on rosario here's
the next delivery he swings it that one
bounces it on the right side it's
stopped by godzilla in the second
baseman on the outfield grass and he'll
throw to first and the ship works there
they get the out on the
grounder to end the inning no runs
couple hits and a couple left for the
indians the bottom of the second is
coming up justin upton will be the next
batter
he is a streaky hitter when things are
going good he will carry a ball club and
whether or not it's a struggle
next pitch and this ball is lifted high
and it's hit deep out into right center
field it's out of here
well maybe upton hurt us talking about
him right there he delivers went the
opposite way and that's a three-run
homer and the angels get back in the
ball game trailing
by a run 5-4
and home run for
upton number
eight of the season
now it's phil gosselin with one out
bases empty vo2
strike called on the outside corner
goslin caught looking
two down in the inning
it's drew butera
who bounced to short his first time up
he's going to try to put what a play by
police but no play at second heads up
base running there by rojas
maybe he read the scouting report that
police act is an above average
maybe elite fielding pitcher
he stretched as far as he could and he
made the catch
another great play defensively
for one of the most athletic pitchers in
the major leagues
runners on the corners
and police act will get an opportunity
to go after anthony rendon who's already
one for two
shift is on
here's the pitch to rendon he swings and
pops it up
right side charging in naylor near the
line makes the catch in fair territory
and please sack works out of the jam
nice work by zach please act we head to
the sixth
here's phil gosling he's over two he's
lined to third struck out
here's the pitch there goes the runner
the pitch is swung on and missed the
throw down is in time
hedges through from his knees and he's
still got him
what a throw by austin hedges hits a
strike him out throw him out double play
and the side is retired
we are headed to the seventh indian
still in front by a run
and this will probably be berea's last
hitter
and if he could get a ball to be hit on
the ground and
reyes has done that here tonight
see if that happens again here today
here's reyes at the plate hits one
sharply to third might be two second for
one and then over to first base and
there we go an inning ending
double play
good job on that one mark langston and
rendon and gosling as well the inning
comes to an end jose iglesias the batter
here's the next pitch this is lifted
high in the air it's hit well out in
left field that ball is carrying and it
is out of here
iglesias
does a little
fist to his chest as he rounds second
base he'll circle the bases he has
homered and
the angels have tied this game up at
five
josh naylor the batter
claudio always from the stretch delivers
and it's swung on and that's lifted high
in the air deep right field and off the
wall
or is it
home run
home run naylor
josh naylor has put the indians in front
with a home run
to right
number four on the season for naylor and
it comes at a great time
upton
with a home run earlier tonight
here's his 2-2
swung on line drive caught by the second
baseman hernandez
right at the top of his leap one down
jose rojas the batter that's the
winning run at the plate
rojas doubled in the fifth
[Applause]
high fly ball
center field ramirez
book it the indians snap a four-game
losing streak